in our last session
we talked about.
the convolution operation on matrices
and we talked about the
the pooling Matrix
and what is purpose was?
today we'll quickly review the first or
I won't say first but the portion
of the notebook that we
Have so far worked on.
but then once we reach
the part where we have to choose the
activation function
and the loss function will have
to
take a detour into the world of probability Theory.
So yes, it's a linear mathematics course, but since
this is neural networks, I mean, we've understood
the Matrix part. We now need to talk about the probability probability
theory part so fully will appreciate.
the probabilistic
context
so first
quick review
of The Notebook
or image classification
then we
want to talk about the
the sigmoid activation function
So this has some prerequisites.
in
probably Theory the purpose of the sigmoid function.
is to
associate a feature
with
a class
so we will talk about this number
we call probability then we will talk about this thing called
odds.
then the log with big function was in the context
of
probability
and then we will see how we derive this function.
now since this is a classification problem, we will
use a loss function for
evaluating this classification model
so we will also talk about
cross
entropy
we cover this. This will be easier. We will
have the we will have covered the preview records to talk
about this.
And then if time allows it I want to talk about.
the fundamental features of recurrent neural
network
so let's call this overview of
the current
so let's begin and of course if there's any question you
have related to anything we've talked about today or
any of the sessions of the past.
We can if we leave 10-15 minutes.
Towards the end of the session.
talk about those
okay.
Let me switch to the notebook.
Let's start from the top. So what we started with the
importing the libraries.
tensorflow
and Keras
and math problem
here is just makes it easier to build a neural
network. We're using tensorflow.
And I thought W. We're using to visualize a sample
of our data.
And the metrics for model, I'm not
sure if we're going to plot the metrics, but I will show you a picture
of it nonetheless if we don't do it in this notebook.
anyway
Let me just make sure I have my reference code opener because
I have several items open here.
It's just bring this over there.
Okay.
Yes, then we proceed to download the dataset.
now Keras
provides
sample data for you to experiment
with with the rich numerical data or
Pectoral data like we're using here the c510 database. It
also comes with pre-trained models. I will talk about pre-trains model
the later on.
But what you're doing here is we're we're going to the data sets
object to download the c410 database.
And we saw that we saw what the pictures were like your tiny images
Square tiny images with that would
fall into one of these 10 classes airplane, you know
the ones you see here.
We talked about the train validation test stages.
And the purpose for dividing a data
set into two or three such splits. You can
see here. We have a
80% is going to the training
data set 20% is going to the test data set.
so
if you had a validation it would be typically a 60.
20 split
Or 50 25 25. The point
is the majority goes to the training data set.
And then we use a math problem
and this for Loop to create a grid of
samples. So a sample from each class.
or a few samples from each class
so this model that we're going to create is very
Basic so it can only predict images of this sort.
If you want to predict something that is much larger
in resolution, maybe even busier than you
would need more.
elaborate Network
But this is a good starting point for us. Let's continue. And then well we
did is we went ahead and instantiated the sequential class which allows us
to add a sequence of layers.
and here we talked about the layers we have the
I have the convolutional 2D layer and always the first
Element in the sequence of layers will
act also as the input layer.
So that is why we have this argument.
That's the activation function. I'll also tell you about value by the way.
I don't listen to the agenda, but I'll tell you about value.
And we'll also go to tensor.
playground tensorflow.com so
I can show you
an animated
illustration of
activation functions and neural networks
We have our Max pooling layer and we do
this a couple of times because if you remember we said that we want to have convo 2D
Max pool converted Max pool so that we can
further.
Extract the important features from the original image.
Then we flatten it because we want to have a distribution. By the
way, when I turn to sigmoid, I'll talk about this. We will
revisit the concept of distribution again.
Not sigmoid the cross entropy.
But anyway, we will go from a matrix that represents
the pictures of the picture to affect your
corresponding to the distribution of
features.
And then finally we end up we have this softmax activation.
And this is something you have to keep remembering is
if softmax is a synonym for sigmoid, but
I'll return to this now. Let me show you the remaining
code.
before we talk about
the softmax or sigmoid
activation function
So if I scroll down here?
I am going to go.
review the
model by typing model
dot summary
the summary method is going to create a table that
indicates our architecture
and the number of parameters of this model has learned.
So if I run this now?
Give it a few seconds for the data set to be downloaded.
And why is it complex?
missing parenthesis
So here you can see your the
architecture of your neuron at work.
And it says here that you can learn this model can
learn a total of 122,000.
parameters
which relative to other pre-trained models this is very
insignificant like the resident 50 model
I think has
six digit or seven digit
so it's it's billions of parameters.
The more you parameters a model can learn.
the well
the more
capabilities the more our variation can handle
anyone heard of gpt3 or gpt2
Once is yes.
So for context gpt3 which is this machine
learning model that can reproduce.
articles
right poems compose music you
can compose music if you go to YouTube and type in GB3
music.
It is at least to Lament.
such as myself
it is it is so beautiful the
music it's indistinguishable from the composition
of a famous composer.
But when you read a poetry you can't tell this is done by robots
or if you read the article in a newspaper.
You can't tell it was written by a machine.
And the gpt3 let's see how many parameters that
model has gpt3 parameters.
Look at that 175 billion.
So they've just taken.
this concept
of learning weights to the extreme
and it's only a matter of time before the even exceed this.
but I mean, this is what I will take for you to do one
or not one or a couple of
things that a human is capable of doing if you remember we talked
about narrow AI this is still narrow AI.
This is still not right. It's not even General AI but it's still
impressive nonetheless.
Okay. So yeah, I mean compared to that this
is this is insignificant, but that's not the point of this is not
like I said to create a production level production ready machine learning
model is just understand.
the linear algebra for
and probability theory for deep learning.
Okay, let's continue. What else do I have we have next?
And then okay. So now that we've trained this model we want to
Train it. So we've built a model we haven't traded yet.
so the train that we're going to use the
compile method
So that the model knows.
Which algorithm to use to back propagate
the weights again, if you watch the video that I
put on Slack?
This idea should be familiar to you.
But the idea is to keep on.
Feeding this neural network these pictures again and again
and again.
and each time
it is fed through the network the updated wage.
Remember we the point here is to adjust the weights.
And bring get the model to predict.
images
with labels that are closest to the original label so we
want
The difference to be eliminated we want to
reduce error to zero.
And empirically we'll do this with cross entropy,
which we'll talk about in a moment.
I'm going to go model. Excuse me model that compile.
the optimizer
is Adam Adam stands for Adam is actually an acronym.
adaptive
I always keep forgetting what it would adaptive something adapt
and I'll go to them.
It's the algorithm for.
There we go, adaptive moment estimation. Look how far I have to come just
to get.
the need for this
Acronym
adaptive moment estimation
Moment.
in statistics is a
is one of the detail that describes the shape of
the data.
So one moment is for example.
Variance, that's the spread of the data.
Another moment is the mean.
The center the central tendency of the data.
Another one is the skewness.
So if it has a long right tail or a left tail and
kurtosis is the peak peakness.
Now this word is borrowed from physics, but it has a slightly different
meaning in physics. But an estimation is
well.
It's prediction.
But the naming name aside this is
going to be used to find the or adjust the weights. Then
we have the loss function.
which is
TF dot Keras
Dot
Sports
categorical
cross
entropy now cross entropy is a loss function.
That can be used.
for binary classification
But in this case since we have every picture you can fall into either one
of 10 classes we want.
Well, we have multi-class classification. So
we will use the sparse variant of
it again. We'll look at the moment of this in a second.
And then we go from logics.
You'll see what a larger it is in a second from large. It's equals true.
and metrics
for a classification the
we have a couple of metrics.
There is accuracy precision and recall.
If this time I will talk about precision and recall.
But basically we want this number to
convert to one.
So we want accuracy to be 100%
but we want the laws cross entropy.
To convert to zero. So again, you're looking at two things the last
function this has to be zero.
The closet is either the better.
And the met the accuracy.
The closer to one the better.
Let me put these on separate lines.
And then we train the model.
compile
and then we go model dot train.
So this is going to learn from the first.
safety
thousand images
but then to evaluate
this model to see if it's overfitting or not. We'll use
the test data set the question the chart.
With the model not be overfitting of the accuracy is 100%
not if it gets to test.
If it does no.
if we look at the metric after training
and if it's a very high score, it's really unlikely to
be 100% But if it's very high.
It could be overfitting. Well, the only way
for us to know if it is overfitting is to get to the test data set.
But if it's poor even from the start even from
the 20% then that's on their fitting so we
don't even need to proceed to the test test it is
that
So yes, if it's perfect 100% something might be.
something might be off because it's
very unlikely for you to get a hundred percent accuracy.
Okay, then what am I looking for? Yes training images.
the train labels which she correspond to the class of
the
picture
and which
Data set. We're going to use for validating.
validation
so for validation, we're going to use a test data set.
So I'm going to go test images.
to pull test images
test
that would be less.
I'm going to run this.
I think cross entropy is one word.
Yeah.
And it's losses dot losses.
Okay.
dot it
careful
And then the other mistake is the epochs number of
epochs.
a box
Epox refers to the number of times you're going to feed this data
through the network.
For larger models you want to be careful with
this? Because if you set a high number of epochs while that
may lead to higher accuracy, it can take
a long time for it to
terminate
so that that particular cell terminate.
so that is why sometimes maybe one upgrade your
Environment in colab you can you have three tiers.
As you keep that in
mind, and this should be validation data.
one more time
Hopefully this won't take more than a few minutes, but I'll just proceed with.
The other lines of code, okay and what
we do after this.
Is let me double check my code.
We are going to
yeah, we will we will evaluate the metrics and then
proceed to predict the sample image.
So I'm at a cell here.
evaluate
model metrics
so we want to look at the loss and the accuracy and then
after that we will go ahead and predict sample image.
the
two steps that we're not going to look at today are
saving the weights of the model. So there are
a few file formats in which you could save the parameters of
the model like CSV. There's one called H5.
And another thing we won't be looking at in this course is deploying the
machine learning model. So go to something like AWS or
Google cloud and deploying this.
Depending on the model you or Library. I should
say you may have to
go to something like compute engine or
An ec2 instance on AWS and
then you would need to use Docker to download the
image and create a container.
So it will go into more of MLPs.
That's what it takes to deploy a machine learning model.
In other cases if using Library like tensorflow on Google Cloud
specifically, you can just upload the script and
Google Cloud will take care of
You know preparing the environment and by environment, I mean installing
operating system on the the hardware.
Installing the right version of python installing the library dependencies.
Process if you want to work on a large ml project in the cloud check out kubeflow.
Yes.
Now I've used a Google Cloud mostly for my
machine learning projects. But yeah, I mean
my point is that we will be going from data science to
data engineering if we
get to that.
And go with that topic.
Maybe we can do a tutorial for that in another session.
Okay, so I can't run these two cells until
that one is done.
Let me at least see what I can do. Okay, let's just
switch then now until this, you know is cooking
at the background.
and talk about
activation functions first
let's talk about
value and then let's talk about softmax.
Keep those who open source producer runs on GCS
or their AWS.
cool
now
I need to visualize a value.
and
talk about the activation.
So let me actually put up the slide.
slides
let's make sure we know what
an activation is and then we'll talk about
activation functions
so
Let me jump to the relevant slide.
Here we go.
Okay, so this is quite busy. So let
me try to
simplify it
I'm going to duplicate this.
And make a copy of this by the way.
I'm going to tap this for big number our course here.
duplicate this
Because I want to remove these labels
for now.
So this is a very simple.
neural network
so this
Is this line of code here?
now, of course for the input, we don't have a tensor
the input for
This network is only two features.
And the dense is three so we have three outputs.
Okay, let's see. Now. We said that neural network are neural
networks.
Our matrices but this is a graphic.
representation
I also have a matrix representation up
here.
Let me see if this one has the activation. This one does have
the activation. Yes.
This is actually what a neural network is doing.
Let me just see if I can remember what this is. Okay. Yeah, so let
me show you the graph representation. Then we'll look at the Matrix since
we've already covered, you know.
matrix multiplication we can
we can talk about this. Let me come up here. So let's say we
have I will use again the
the real estate example
And let's say this is a
very simple.
classification model
so
we want to classify a property.
By its category. So for example, is it a warehouse?
or is it a
is an apartment a residential apartment?
Or let's say commercial property like an office
space in a building or apartment residential apartment.
So how are they different you can have two properties that are similar in
size?
but
with offices you have less.
partitioning
you have fewer doors because you don't have any rooms.
No kitchen. Maybe you have a kitchen you don't
have a
balcony
and maybe it's just
What's the word I'm looking for more open?
Like there are no enclosing there are no partitioning essentially.
so let's say I want is
the number of
rooms in the property and number two is the
size of the property exactly wrong open
floor plan.
Open floor plan.
So obviously there's more to
there's more things that could describe
to distinguish these two but again a point
here to understand what an activation is.
And this is the context of really the rectified linear.
What does it stand for I keep forgetting I will I'll take you
to the side of the moment. But here we go.
I1 is the
number of rooms I2 is the size of
the property.
And we have three.
Perceptrons in our one hidden layer. So
this is one hidden layer.
one input one hidden one output
What comes out of this output layer?
is
is the is the classification is a type
1 a property or the type 2 property? Okay. Let's
see how this is done.
So what we do is if you look at these arrows that stem
from for example I2.
I too will send to every perceptron.
It's value.
However
It is not just setting the feature. It is also sending a
random weight and a different way to each
perceptron.
So for example, they first perceptron
might get a weight of 5.
The second perception may get a weight of one.
And the third perceptor may get a weight of 10.
So one perceptron will consider the feature to
be someone important on another one not so
important another one very important.
And then we do the same thing with the first feature.
We send.
The value to all three perceptrons, but we associated with
the with different weights.
That's what the slide is about.
So this is nothing more than
some arithmetic
So here we can see we have the feature multiplied by
its random weight.
We have the second feature.
and of course all of this
arithmetic is happening inside the crystal chapter. That's
what you that's why you have this summation.
or this Sigma Sigma represents summation
the
integral sign here actually refers to the
well, this is used for continuous values,
right?
This is used for continuous value. So if you have discrete value you use the
sigma if you have continuous values you have.
a definite integral
anyway
We multiply each feature by its rather wait.
So you only have two features here. So.
And since this is for the first picture perceptron, we'll
multiply it by its way and then we have the the sum of the products.
so let's say
that
this sum is 32.
We will then take this number 32 and pass it to the
activation function this Greek letter of Phi.
represent the activation function
which what does this activation function? Well, it depends.
It depends on what you use.
For your layer if I bring
you what let me keep a note. What's the slide number one five two? So
if I take you to the slide for the activation functions
these are the
activation functions you can choose
so this is the rectified linear unit.
For the others, I'll show you. I'll take you to the playground to talk
about this.
now for the
for any layer, except the output layer you never
want to use
A linear activation function or here as
it's known as the identity function.
because
well, let me tell you about let me tell you how really works
and then you'll see why you don't want to use a linear function.
If you remember we said that a
Neural network has a basic component which we
call the perceptron and the perceptron is supposed
to be a mathematical model.
of a human brain neuron
and a neuron will pass a signal.
Forward if the signal is strong enough.
In the context of new networks if it's relevant enough the
value function.
well, establish this
threshold
so the value is for
setting a threshold.
Let me show you something else. I did not talk about.
This is slide 108 if I return to 152.
You will notice we have these arrows.
These arrows are biases.
so
let me take you to this mod
so I can graph it for you.
there's Mass graphic calculator very nice application this
This much.
so
I don't suppose we could do piecewise here.
But I think I have a slide here.
It was one of
eight
See if I think if I can do this in Desmos or
not.
But I don't know how to set a range.
Okay.
There's more.com. Yeah, I
think I'm going to have to draw this out drawing it
out will be.
a lot faster
Let me quickly. Let me quickly join Zoom here.
Because I have to move the graph around and not sure how to
do it in decimals.
Or no, I can't do it online here.
Sorry about going back and forth. I'm just trying to do this in the most.
Efficient way possible I can draw
diagram here. So let me
create a new one.
as let's say this is
our code that
hot
thanks. Yeah, I I've also used you. I mean I played around with
future but since I'm not, you know
fluent, I don't want to play around
like I don't want to waste time but this is
simple. Okay. So this is our this is our coordinates system.
Yes and the value
does this the value?
will
evaluate to zero for every value of x
except for
when you set
a threshold now in the value that we see here. The threshold
is zero.
This is our bias.
the bias here
is assumed to be
is 0
Okay, so
let me do the following. I'm going to come over here and let
me
change this to the color red.
and we want
it to be linear for every point of x.
After zero is this linear? It is almost linear. Let's
bring it up here that
So this is the one x axis.
And let's say the x-axis is the size of the property.
Okay.
And the y axis is the activation.
the strength of the signal so to speak
I will use.
There we go.
So the y axis.
Is the activation?
the
this is actually the size of the property times.
the weight
the random weight. So let's say if I
come back to our slides. I think it was W sub
2i, but it's a wait just a wait just
some random weight
Okay.
and here the bias is set to zero,
which means
it is 0
so the origin
okay.
if I return to this unbiased activation
function
I don't like to use the word unbias because it has a
specific meanings statistics.
but if you look at this activation function here
the bias is set to 0.
so which means that I mean, it's like an if an
else, they've been right f of x will give you 0
for any value of x that is less than 0 so basically
any negative numbers that is negative value is going to
squish it to zero.
but if any value is equal to 0 or above 0
then you will get a you will get the linear you will get
an identity. So if you get five.
You'll basically really will let
it through as long as it's above zero.
But let's do this experiment or Let's
do let's talk about a hypothetical situation.
suppose
this is our
customized value
so I'm going to go text.
Preview it.
And then we will say it is the function
represented by f of x.
And this will be a piecewise function. So begin.
cases cases
It will give you.
zero
if
the value of x is
greater than
the bias
Excuse me.
Less than the bias.
and it will give you
X
itself
if
it is equal to
basically greater than or equal to the bias.
Yes.
Like a simple if enough statement.
If it's less than bias.
Zero equal to or above bias.
X letter through
So, let me tell you what device does let me
ask a question.
how
Big does a property have to be.
What is the minimum minimal size the smallest of
property has to be for to
be considered?
Either an office or an apartment.
I think if if you're in, New York.
That the better what's the
like you can go very small, but what's what's the smallest?
I'm not a real estate expert on a property developer, but how let's
and you let's use a square square feet.
How small?
Can you go?
Without like like it won't
be like we don't want to go as small as being a wardrobe but how small can
we go before we say this is no longer enough. It's no
longer a property. This is just
A cabinet, you know, what's the smallest
size for an apartment?
in square feet
anybody
200 square feet
Fine then Richard. Thank
you for the answer. We have now set the bias to be equal to 200 square
feet.
Now you'll see this hopefully fall into place. We will
set the bias.
To be good to 200.
Basically, we are doing this.
If we set the device 200, we're going to shift this.
200 points to the right
imagine if I bring it over here.
Okay.
We have shifted.
the bias 200 points
Okay, what are we doing here?
Suppose we take we have some property.
And I will use this point to represent that problem. Let's make
this a very small observation.
Okay.
this represents
the size times weight
of this property
if the property is
let's say one.
100 I can't even put it exactly on
the line. So let's just put it here. Let's say
this property is 150 square feet.
Because it is below our threshold.
We don't even considered a property.
So it's activation will be zero.
so
f of x or if you or equivalently if you want 5 of
x
I want to be consistent with the slides.
The activation for this particular X will be zero.
Because it's not a property.
What if we make it one?
You know 190 still not a property
not qualified to be a property.
But once it gets 200 or above. Oh, well, then
we will let it through.
That's what I mean by strength of the signal.
If we had a stack of hidden layers, it
would not even get to the next layer because what's the point of figuring
because see the way we're going to determine
if it's a office or a real estate is to see how big it
is how many partitions?
How many windows the height
of the ceiling Maybe?
How many fire extinguishers?
How many glass because of
Open Space is really they have these glass?
Like you don't have well like you have you have
a b you have view like class Glass Walls. I
don't know how to call it.
So what's the point of counting the number of rooms and
the height of the ceiling and the number of fire extinguishers if
it's even if it's too small to even be considered an
apartment, that's what this value is going to do.
Products thank you rob by the way, all of this all of
this channel is going to be saved. Okay.
All of the chats from all sashes have been saved. So
some make you try to make accessible for all of you. Later.
That's what they're really function does.
So if I return if I return here to the
the
slides if I return to one five two
That's what we try to indicate. So if you see here, let's say
the okay this one this activation function
for this example. The bias is set to zero.
So when we take this sum of this product 32
because 32 is about the bias. It
will let we will let it through same thing for 55 with
letter through but for negative 4 we crush it
down to zero.
then once we get to this point
We will also do we will multiply this activation
by its weight.
This activation by its weight this activation by
its weight.
So this one?
Since the signal was very weak.
It will remain zero even when it reaches
this downstairs. So for example
Let's say this particular property.
has
its size is below the threshold.
That's already a red flag. It's not big enough for us to consider the
property.
but it has a door and it has
a window
But because this signal from this perceptron
is very weak.
And we have another activation function here. We will classify as
not property.
but I talked about binary classification, so
I guess it could be a very
small office.
Like, you know when you go to currency exchange.
They have these very small booths.
So I guess you can call that an office.
The example I'm giving is not perfect, but
hopefully understand the purpose of the rally function. That's really what
I'm trying to emphasize you.
Now, let me quickly show you the Matrix representation of
the same.
I be yeah.
Here we have our input vector vector and we multiplied by The
Matrix of Weights. These cells are
in Black because these the stand for
their weight. Excuse me the bias.
so the threshold for the activation function
of course the order of
Matrix multiplication is not Computing commutative.
So the number of rows must match the
number of columns in the excuse me. The number of columns must match the
number of rows.
for the vector or Matrix on the right, so we multiply this
and we will get
a new vector
and what is this Vector? What are the components of the vector? Well,
it's this part. It's the sum.
It's still wait more. It's the random weight multiplied
by the bias.
It's the input first input multiplied
by its weight the second to put multiply its weight and we
do this for all three perceptrons so really
And that this is what it is. So if
we would if we would take the sum of these products.
this would be the components of the
hidden layer
And then what we do?
Is we pass this vector?
And I'm using Z here because that's the convention
for Activation to this activation function.
And what the activation function will do is it will go
through these components.
Check the signal.
This one is negative 4 so it will be brought down to zero and then
what we're going to do is we're going to again append the bias
term the bias numerical value.
added to the
to the vector
this activation Factor will then be passed on to the
the output layer
if you notice
this Vector corresponds to
this so 32. This is
one that this whole part is the one
vector.
We have three components.
And these three components from the vector and this Vector will
be passed to the activation function of the last perceptron.
And that's what we have here.
So we do this.
dot product
and then we will have a single component.
Once again, we'll output this to the activation function.
the return value of this actually the evaluated value of
this activation function is
zero
So imagine we're trying to do we would try to do binary classification.
Is this a property or not?
So let's say because the property was
too small.
The signal was too weak. And so we classified it
as a non-property.
And this is true if you want to for example classify something
as fraud or not fraud spam or not spam.
And that's really the idea.
Okay.
now
let me show you this other slide. This is from another very well at book.
Which I have here on my on my desk. The book
is called.
fundamentals of machine learning and predictive data analytics
this is from
MIT press again. I'll include the book.
in the references file
but this is hopefully going to help you understand the concept
intuitively suppose we have
a picture with a triangle in it
this one
and we want to know what it is that we're looking at.
each
perceptron and now we only have one hidden layer. So this is a
very simplified example.
each perceptron in this hidden layer
is going to look at one feature of this picture.
So for example, if you see here we have.
One segment of the triangle here. We have another segment
of the triangle here. We have another yet another segment of
the triangle.
the second here the layer
Is going to combine the information from the previous end layer.
And I will say oh we are forming an angle.
So that's one angle form. That's one.
And I want to use the word feature, but that is one.
Part of the picture that this machine learning has discovered.
And the same thing for the second perception of the Hidden layer.
And you can see once we pass these two.
And by the way, they're vectors. So it is a vectors of
the features. We pass this to the Apple layer. Then
the perceptron will put these two pieces of puzzles
together and it will say okay we're looking at a triangle. So this
is supposed to be an intuitive approach.
Now before I take the sigmoil, let me actually take it the
playground playground that tensorflow so you can see why you would
use other activation functions.
playground
tensorflow
let me tell you what we were looking at
here.
First this is the neural network.
this entire section
you have your features your input Dimensions if
we use tensorflow terminology.
your hidden layers
now
there is no hard rule or formula.
for choosing the number of hidden layers
but for most problems
two hidden layers is sufficient.
for most problems
or at least numerical problems data, that
is numerical and
Like if you're doing regression.
For that so from majority problems. This is this is
this architectures sufficient for things like pictures and
Sound sound bites or text. No you do.
You definitely need more elaborate neural network, and
then you have the output layer.
So this entire thing is your neural network?
Then up here we have.
the hyper parameters
Remember, we should hyper parameters are synonymous with
the configuration of the null Network.
This will allow you to run this for.
different number of epochs so you can keep feeding your
data to the network to see
In how it's doing?
And then you have these hyper parameters, which allow you
to control.
how the model learned and
how to control its the overfitting
so we have we can choose the learning rate.
the regularization function
the regularization rate
and then here
illustrate
how effective and neural network is
They have chosen some very unusual.
Shapes of data. I mean, this is look at this look at what's
going on here.
This is supposed to be like a scatter plot. We have two types
of data two data classes. The blue
one is centered.
In the middle and the second class is around again.
You're unlikely to see something like this in in the real
world. This is supposed to be like a extreme example.
The point of this demonstration to show you how a new network is still
able to classify.
the
two classes in the data set
Here's another one.
Here's another one. This is easier.
And there's another one. Yeah, I mean, this is look at this. This is
the point that what now?
I have to play around with this, but we can use the
same Nola work.
to completely separate
these
observations
now, how do we
separate
we need to talk about regression for a moment.
If I come back to this slide if I go all the way to
up here.
This is supposed to be a picture that illustrates the
application of the general regression model
regression is used for.
modeling the direction of the data
and that's how you forecast. That's
an application of forecasting or others known as a regress.
It's called regression because
in a
forecasting model the observations should
regress towards this line.
A regression model this is obviously not linear because
well it's curved can also be used to separate the
data.
into two groups if in the case of
a binary classification
So this would be a polynomial model.
And the idea is to draw the boundaries or
to draw boundary.
Or rather model the boundary of the data set.
Of course, it won't be perfect. So yeah, I hope you can see on my screen. We have
some light green observations some like green data points.
in the second cluster
Conversely we have some of these dark green or turquoise.
If you like to call it in the first cluster.
But the majority have are well partitioned.
now
here's another reason why you can never want to use a linear model for
classification because it's linear. It's
a single line. You cannot use a single line.
To partition a sea of data points like the
one you see here, like imagine if this were a straight line you could not
clearly.
delineate
this section
You can't also do this with our value
model either.
Unless of course.
You use multiple ready models. Let me let me
demonstrate.
If we come back here.
I'm going to return to the
first example
I will not change the hyper parameters.
And I will not change the neural network. I will not
change the configuration.
I'm gonna have to play.
and what I want you to look at
is
the animation in here
now what you're going to see is this epox are quickly going
to increment.
like some sort of
time-lap
and what each Epoch another thing you will see here is that
is the loss?
And we probably care for the loss. We want this
to converge to zero and it will be animated here. So
if I hit let's let's watch what happens. Okay, so you want to watch
you want to watch this and you want to watch this
space over here?
And we want to see if you're able to use for.
Really you models.
not linear
not polynomial. We want to see if we can use that really
that L. Looking model four of them.
to delineate
the boundaries of these two classes ready
one, two three
All right. Look at the loss function is already converging to zero you
see how it has climbed down.
It is getting closer and closer to zero. We are not
at how many epochs 100 200 I'm
gonna hit pause 236 epochs watch
what has happened.
You see these boundaries.
These are formed by those four.
value functions
1 2 3 4 I can see here. We have formed the first.
Angle and this is the second angle.
Put these together.
and you're able to
you know separate these two
clusters of data.
Is it clear like has this example have to
understand what we're doing? What if I had said? Okay, by
the way, this is 10 age. I should have changed us to value.
Let me say this to rally and try again.
One two three, I'm gonna hit play so you can see it still
does a good job.
Obviously the corners are sharper.
But that's what really does.
What if I would set this to linear?
and hit play
it's not able to.
Because there's nothing linear about the pattern of
this data.
Let's try this other one.
and I'm gonna use
Value again, and I'm gonna hit play.
And sometimes you actually have to restart this for to work properly. So I'm going
to
hard refresh this
Try again.
There we go.
You can clearly see the value right now.
And for something like this, well, you need
something that is more curved like
ten age I hit play.
This might take a while longer.
so the loss is
a climbing
it's
consistent
I think I'm gonna have to a hard refresh.
To run this again.
So 10 age can it play once more?
I remember this example always takes a bit longer.
But it is ultimately able to you know.
separate
these two classes
Okay, look at the loss is is dropping. It's
getting closer and closer to zero very slowly, but it is
still not good enough.
That this let's let it run a little longer.
It's 300. Is it gonna go down to 200?
Look at that. Look at that. Look at that.
We're almost 1,000 epochs.
and
the test loss is kind of stuck at 300.
So what we might have to do is play around
with these hyper parameters like
change the regularization rate.
even adjust a bad size
But it's kind of oh look at that. Hold on. Hold on
what something's happening?
It is it's dropping again. It's dropped some more.
That's 1500 epochs.
I'm gonna I don't know if I should keep running this.
But it is it's done somewhat. Well, I mean the Tesla is
still not.
Good enough if we wanted to get closer to zero.
But clearly we want to use this activation function.
I think we had pause here.
But yes had I
played around with this with the hyper parameters. I could
have gotten it to perfectly.
You know separate the two classes.
Okay.
I'll put the link in the chat, but but it will
be also put this in the slide so you don't know you can you can check this
out later on play around with it.
now, let me return to the
notebook. I think it's done.
And if we look at our model.
After 10 epochs, it's accuracy has
gone from 36% or almost 37%
to 75% accuracy.
It's loss.
Its loss is well, not very good.
It's not even zero.
But we could have in order to improve the loss function we could
increase the number of epochs but even then.
Our data is a problematic because
it's very small and our neural network
is quite simple. Anyway, the accuracy is not
that so 75% of the time.
we should
Not 75% about 75% accuracy. We should
get the picture that the model is looking. Yeah. So,
let's see how this happens then I'll return and talk about
Sig more than cross entropy.
But we only have 15 minutes left. Okay, so let me do this quickly.
I am going to upload a picture.
from the C4 10 database
Okay.
I will use.
cast to load the image
So I'm going to go.
Keras
I'll leave this. I'll leave this out for now just for
the sake of time, but basically I was only going to plot.
The metrics actually, I think I have the code.
I can just copy paste that so many copy paste it.
I'm gonna copy paste.
test
images
test out BLS
and the metrics we want this to be
Oh, I was supposed to assign to this
a variable.
to this mistake
No problem.
I'll share this notebook with you you can run it but what
we need to what we need this, you know the plot
it but I won't plot this right now. I'm just going to comment it out and
I'm just gonna show you a sample classification.
So I'm going to
load the image.
so
simple image
and I will use the
load image function from Keras
to take this cat picture
Which is from C4.
This is a PNG.
And I
need to specify its Dimensions which of course is 32
by 32.
and then
I need to convert it to an array and then normalize it.
So I'm going to go to sample image.
image dot img2 array
into a numpy array
test
or sample image
and then
sample image
equals
dot reshape
so we have
one sample
That is 32 by 32 or 3
color channels.
And then we want to normalize. So this is normalize.
So what I mean by normal, so we have three color channels in
each color channel the brightest pixel. So
for example, if it's the red channel the most red pixel will
have value 255.
And at least read pixel would
be zero.
We want a normalize it because
the Machinery models don't understand.
What these values are?
And moreover if you remember the slides that
we looked at when we I was talking about the Matrix operation of
new light works. It will throw off our arithmetic.
So to normalize it well we do is we take this sample image.
And since it's a numpy object.
We can divide it by 255.
So if a number is 255 if it's like in the red Channel It's Perfectly
red. It will be one.
Otherwise it will be 0 so I will now run this.
and
this is supposed to be Target size.
Okay, so if I show you what the sample images you will
see it's
A multi-dimens. It's a tensor, basically.
And all about this is what we mean by normalized. So this is 77% of
the pixel.
brightness
okay, then what I'm going to do is I'm going to use the
Predict method so I'm going to go.
predicted
class
index
will be equal to model.
dot predict
Sorry predict, the classes predict classes
because it's a classification model and Sample.
sample image
and then I'm going to cast the index.
as an integer, so let me show you what happens if I
run this method
sequential object
and see I think the mistake somewhere if I
scroll up here.
softmax
Yeah, that's correct.
All right. Let me see. I have to actually combine code from two separate
notebooks predict.
Okay, let's try this. Let me try predict on its own.
it
cake you see we have a distribution.
Which means?
This is the shape.
That the model has predicted.
So remember we said that a machine learning every thing whether it's
a property or a picture or sound bite.
Will be sort of associate with the shape. This is
the shape of the data.
Now what I need to do?
Is use the right code?
Let me try this one more time.
paste
Okay.
Okay, and then
I have image classes. So what's this gonna
give us?
And then if I scroll up here.
We want to pass this index.
into the into the list
so we go test labels.
pass in the result
and
Something is missing in my code.
result is
for yeah, I think this is it.
Okay.
Because I had to mix two two notebooks, but this is
the idea.
Now to understand what this is we need to talk about.
the
the sigmoid or I keep seeing sigmoid here.
We use a soft Max function.
We talk about softmax.
And then we will talk about the cross entropy so
might go a few minutes a couple of minutes over our
session. But I mean this is this is really
important. This is good stuff relevant stuff.
Okay, so I actually have my notes here from before.
Okay, let me save this.
And call this activation functions.
Let me show you a picture of softmax function.
And they're very similar in that they are.
used for
assigning to every
feature distribution
a
class in the case of Sigma. It will be a binary classification.
And the case of softmax it will be.
multi-class classification
but we have this s looking curve.
and if a feature is
You know below the threshold.
it will be given 0 if it's binary and one
otherwise
Okay.
No, we have to look at it mathematically pictorially it won't help very
much.
Classification let's put softmax.
Yeah, let's let's talk about the math. The math will help.
Okay.
Let me first begin with.
a binary example
and then we can generalize it for multi-class classification. So
before I talk about softmax, let me talk about sigmoid first.
Because it's easier to talk about.
It's easier to derive the sigmoid function because it's binary.
And the prerequisites are this.
and to do this
I'll just take you to this other application I've built.
I used to you sometimes users for teaching it's
called a box map.
It bring us over here.
Okay. So these are the few in
order for us to understand the sigmoid function otherwise known as expert. These
are the prerequisites.
So I'm going to open each box.
and quickly take you through the
the
explanation the sigma function is giving by this formula.
So, let's see what this is. Why why this this?
mathematical expression will produce
that that's looking in line. We just looked at.
Okay, so, let's see. Let's derivation.
first of all, if the number of probability is a
number between a real number between 0 and
so
and it's given by this number is given by a ratio. It is
the total outcomes.
In the denominator and the chosen outcomes on
the numerator. So for example, let's consider flipping a coin.
or flipping
two coins
And you want to know what is the probability of getting getting either
heads and tails or two tails or two heads?
The total number of outcomes are these three
you can get two heads two tails or one
heads and tails and this is a combination not a
permutation so we don't care about the order of the coin.
So it doesn't matter if you get it tells her hairs or heads or tails with the
same thing.
Anyone know what is a probability of getting two tails?
All you well, there's only one such.
outcome
from your total number of outcomes. So that's one over three or
33%
if we can round it up to 34% if you want.
The chance of getting it tails on the Tails when you flip
two coins.
Is 33%
That's probability.
Okay.
A several example is flipping one coin. How many outcomes you
have? You only have two heads or tails. So what is it probably
of getting your heads?
50%
Your total number of outcomes is two and then you're chosen outcome
is one. So 1 over 2. That's 50%
Of course, assuming you have a perfectly balanced coin.
Then we have odds.
Odds is a is the ratio of two probabilities.
For example, you want to know what is the probability of getting a
let's say you have two people who are very making
a bet.
And we want to know who has a higher probability of winning the bet.
One person bets on getting a tails and Tails. The
other person gets bets on getting either heads or
heads.
or heads and tails
so they have
a higher probability because they have more
the their number of chosen outcomes is greater.
And you might say this is unfair. Well so are many so
is the real world, right? So for example in horse betting
people who can buy more bets have more number of
outcomes if they better more horses naturally have
a higher probability of winning.
Whereas if I buy if I put all my money on one
horse. Well, I have a smaller problem and that's that's what
odds is the odds of that. Let's say you have
bet on three horses or in this case. Let's say it's two
because we have your number of choice. Your number
of outcomes is closed the total number of outcomes.
You'd have a higher probability. So if you compare your
probability versus my probability, that's the odds ratio.
The odds would be in your favor you would
have twice.
The odds of you winning is twice as high.
We'd also the probability as toys as how you say the odds is
twice as high.
because if we divide your probability over my
probability we will get to
okay.
now
another way to express the same ratio.
is to
Take my probability and subtract it from one. Why
because well
There are three outcomes three three possible outcomes.
I have taken one of them.
So there are two remaining.
So out of the 100% of the outcomes I
have taken.
33% of it
That's what 1 minus 3 is. Oh, that's why we
have one minus p t t so if I had
no.
If you are taking all three.
Outcomes you would have 100% probability of winning
because you have bet on all three outcomes. But if I take
one of them you have one less than the entirety. That's
what we have one minus PTT. Either way. You will get the same
number.
Okay. Now why do we want to re-express the
problem the express the odds ratio in this
way because this is going to bring us to log on.
the log on it's about taking the
now if you see here what we have done is we
have inverted.
the ratio
Okay. So this was P of X in the
denominator and one minus P of X in the numerator here.
We have just flipped it. I just
reversed in the previous example this you can understand the odds and the
anal index and the analog of two people betting and one
has
they have the luxury of more chosen outcomes than
the other person.
but if we flip it around
we will get
We will still have the ratio but we have a problem.
the reason we use logarithm
In any context of probability, so there's something called likelihood and
maximum likelihood you may have heard of this. The reason we
use a lot a logarithmic function is to change the
scale of the probability. You see the number can be
very small if I have for example
0.05 probability over
let's say
one minus P of X. It will be 1 minus.
0.5.
You see the probability is very small.
0.5%
and
in the case of multi-class classification, you will
have all of these very tiny properties 5% 1% less
than 1%
So for arithmetic purposes and in particular
competition purposes
We want to kind of rescale.
The probability so for example, if I take 5% and I
put it in the logarithmic function and the base of
the logarithm is not really important. I have changed the scale.
So it's not one point negative 1.3.
Okay, so really what I want to get across is this
the choice of the base is not that important.
But we want to apply the log rhythmic function just to change
the scale. And of course log base of e is just a natural log with
natural logarithm.
Okay.
Then we have the logic function. The largest function is
really that when you apply the logarithmic function
to your odds, that's where you call the logic function.
So let me zoom out.
So the expression we saw previously, that's the logic.
And it turns out when you evaluate this
expression it is the same thing as evaluating beta
Sub Zero and Beta Support. Now, what is better Sub Zero
better sub one
These are the coefficients.
of the regression model
so
did I reference to the regression model anywhere else?
Not here.
The regression model is given by this. Let me
type it very quickly.
And I think I actually have it here generalized.
Yes, this is it.
aggression
So let's move this up here.
And for Simplicity, let me remove the other.
Variables and let's just say we have two.
You have two variables.
The Epsilon is the residual.
That's the error rate. Let me not include that
in here either just really keep it simple.
and let's just have beta sub 1
so beta Sub Zero is what we call the bias term.
Or the why it's the number on the wall by intercept.
So in the value function, the bias was in the x-axis in
the general regression model devices and the y axis
this is the y-intercept.
and this is the
x sub 1 is the feature and this is
its weight.
Now we talk we'll talk about real estate size of the
property number of bedrooms Etc.
X sub one is one
feature and beta sub one. It's it's the weight associated with
the correct weight associated with it.
Okay.
That's where beat us up 0 and better someone come from.
so if we return to this the logic function
the
Numerical value that we will get from a validity this expression
is the same as that expression.
now
if we apply if we want to get rid of the logarithm if
you want to change the scale again.
We will have to take this expression.
And raise it to the exponential function
to cancel to eliminate log.
And that's what we're doing here.
We've taken the expression above.
And raise it to e but that
mean but this is algebra. So we have to do with the other side as well.
Then of course e to the power log e will get
eliminated.
and this expression
Oops, this expression comes down here.
Now in order to derive the sigmoid function, we have to do some
algebraic manipulation.
Which is going to be a multiple steps to what I'm going to do is I'm going to
avoid that instead what I've done.
is I have
created
if you can go to symbol lab what you looked at before to basically
move one minus P of x to the other side and
then after a little bit of algebraic manipulation.
We get this.
This is the formula. Basically this is odds. This
is the odds.
In the context of binary classification we asking
what is the what is the probability of it being
this class versus being in that class? What
is that? Probably of being of this particular?
feature
being fraud versus not front.
What is a odds of this being?
Well, actually probability so we have taken the concept of odds and
we have now representing as making it a probabilistic
number. So what is it now the probability of
being a Spam versus the probability of not being spam. What
is it? What is the probability of it being?
An animal versus that probably of it not being in and that's the
idea here.
Okay.
so this is very
sped up.
explanation of
the sigboid function
So what do we will do is then every time we get a feature?
it will be a
it's valuable be inside.
The probability of it being in a class
versus the probability of not being in the class.
Okay.
and so that's what
the sigmoid is going to do.
if it could if it goes above the threshold it will classify
as
let's say fraud if it falls below the threshold will classify as
non-front binary classification.
So the observations will end up up here or down here.
Let me see if I can see one with the observations on it.
Yeah, and apparently sigmoid is a term used
in medicine as well.
Come to think of it. I actually have a notebook where I
have visualized all of this.
but it's already 15 minutes past the
The time and we don't have we still haven't got into
cross entropy.
Alright, I'll do this. I have the notebook. Let me just show you let me
show you the picture. I mean, let me show you and I'm
GitHub.
But I'll put the I'll put the notebook on
slack. The comments should be self-explanatory or is
the let me show you where it is.
statistics with python
It's one of these notebooks. Let me open them all.
Yeah.
Here's one.
I think this is the one.
Yeah, so you can go I'll put this.
I'll put this link in this is of course some GitHub you
can access it. You don't need anything, but I'll
share this with you. Just go to the
sales one by one.
So you can see this is the this is
what the sigmoid function does, right it plots it on
this on this s looking.
I mean, this is this this is this you're seeing
them. This is the model plotting. It's
not the actual observations is the model of the observations.
And if you if you draw a line.
you will get this red line, but what the
the expert function does
is
like you're seeing here it will.
push it up to one if it's
if it's a true if it's a truth classification and bring
it all the way down to zero to false classification.
That's really what I try. I mean, I'm trying to speed up
the explanation.
Okay.
and we didn't talk about I mean did
There is also recall and accuracy. I said
we talk about this if we have time, but we don't have anymore much we gonna have much
more time. Let me also remind you about this.
six days from now we have the second
episode of
the ml papers
by the way, I strongly check this out because we're also now
an ambassador of deep learning AI.
Which means if you participate in your
complete a survey from Deep learning AI you
can get a 50% discount on any one of the courses on
Coursera.
So in in case you don't know deep learning
they that AI is founded by.
Andrew Ong
I mean, I think everybody knows that he's the Stanford professor
of
Machine learning, you know, he's the one who founded Coursera.
And that very famous machine learning course.
So we know I applied that we we got accepted
as Ambassador. So, you know if you scroll down to the details.
Yeah, if you participate you can.
Get a 50% discount on the course.
Now I did promise to allocate 10
minutes or so for any questions. And since this is the last
course first of all, I appreciate that. You know, you stayed with me now 17
minutes past the
session but
I'm gonna try to give you the remaining material anyway.
But let me worry. This is now beyond the algebra like we've
got personally not up. This is now in the realm of probability Theory.
probability Theory and statistics
But let me just maybe for a few more minutes
see if you have any questions suggestions questions about
this session anything anything the past anything in
the future?
now there are more courses coming up
I'm going to for
August
our post about this on the slack Channel
I'm also going to send everybody an email to
complete a survey.
And you will be rewarded for the the
survey slash testimonial. So do check
it out. I'll try to send it to you also not
send it to you today.
Especially for those of you who are participating.
Who participate in all of these sessions but
let me stop talking for second any questions or comments.
Anything you know, you you want to because by the way once wants
to the session is over. I'm going to keep on
adding improvements.
like the short video tutorials notebooks
here and there. Thank you.
Is that Rudy or is that Ramsey? I don't
know. I can't see your first name in the chat. But thank you very much. No
questions or comments.
no suggestions
Well, if you do have suggestions and you're not going to answer now, do
do fill out the survey, please I'll really
appreciate it.
And I will try to make it worth your while.
Well, today's notebooks Beyond. Yeah, the notebooks will definitely all
the markdown files and what I usually do
after every Workshop is I clean up the I clean up
the files at comments.
And put the coding the markdown file
Jupiter notebook all on the
dashboard.
For sure.
The only questions no more comments.
Very good in that case.
Do check your email?
I will send it in a few hours that I do have a
look at the email.
and
yeah, do keeps do stay
tuned on the main slide Channel.
Because I'm going to post.
updates
For the upcoming course that starts in August.
And for now, let me thank you very much for joining me, especially for
those of you who join me for all.
these four weeks
and I look forward to your response
in the email about to send you.
And I look forward to seeing you in the next session.
So until then for now, take care. Enjoy the
rest of your day.
I'll see you soon. Bye.